the biden administration has yet to call
it a crisis but the homeland security
secretary admitted this morning quote
we are on pace to encounter more
individuals on the southwest border
than we have in the past 20 years sarah
sanders served as white house press
secretary for president trump
and is now running for governor in
arkansas
congratulations on your run good to see
you sarah
uh so important to get your perspective
on this because you would have been the
last
press secretary for a white house to
deal with something that
looks like what we're dealing with but
i've heard even you say
it's not the same how
well let's look at the situation
certainly i think the media served as
the propaganda arm for the biden
campaign and they're doing the exact
same thing
in the administration they continue to
prop
up the biden administration they're not
holding them accountable
the facts are clear when president trump
instituted the remain and poli remain in
mexico policy and put up a border wall
it was effective and it worked
president biden's administration has
actually
caused a humanitarian and national
crisis
at our border by opening them up at a
time when democrats are fighting
to keep our schools our businesses and
our churches closed
they're completely opening our border
it's a total disgrace
the bottom line is when you open the
borders and you invite people to come
here illegally
they do and that's exactly what we're
seeing happen on our southern border
and people are flooding in we do not
have the ability or the capacity to
handle it
and it is creating a massive
humanitarian and national crisis at the
border
and that's a direct result of the biden
administration's failure
to deal with it and certainly allow it
to continue
i want to get to this so we can watch it
together current white house press
secretary jinsaki yesterday was
asked if there was a border disaster
given biden
having called fema to deal with the
migrants
let's watch the last administration
left us a dismantled and unworkable
system
and like any other problem we are going
to do everything we can
to solve it i know that we always get
into the fun of labels around here but i
would say our focus is on
solutions this is a big challenge and it
certainly is a reflection of
using every level of the federal
government to help address that
sarah sanders what's your reaction to
jin saki
look she's certainly entitled to her own
opinion but she's not entitled to her
own facts
the trump administration's policy
specifically the remain in mexico policy
and the border wall and other measures
that the trump administration put into
place
we're working at securing our border
look we want people to come into this
country but
we want them to do so legally and
through the correct
process they not only opened our borders
but they encouraged people to come
to our country again at a time when
they're shutting
the rest of the country down they're
opening up our border
they created this problem by their
failure to understand
the situation at the border and they're
continuing to make it worse
by not addressing it they have complete
and total
failure right now at the border and i
think kevin mccarthy is exactly right if
they want to deal with some of the
crisis going on in this country
it's to go down there look these people
in the eye and understand the crisis and
the
problem that they have caused and they
have created
in our southern states and at our
southern border
uh do you think that the biden people
are going to get harassed
like you did because i remember you were
in a restaurant with your family this
was going on
just to remind everybody and you're
good-spirited about it but it was
worrisome do you think that's going to
happen for
for the biden administration frankly i
hope not that's not who we are as a
country
i didn't like it when it happened to me
and i certainly don't want to see that
happen to somebody
else but i do want to see them held
accountable i want to see the media
ask them hard questions and i want to
see them address the problem and fix it
i don't wish what happened to me on even
my worst enemy
in fact i think that's the opposite of
how we should deal with something
but i do want them to address the
problem i want them to recognize that it
exists which i think is something they
have failed to do
so far and i want them to take steps to
fix it and i want the media to continue
to ask
hard questions and hold them accountable
until they do it
i want the president to uh start talking
to the media
that would help do all those things that
you just mentioned can we get person one
to answer question one all right we'll
move to this
president biden is touring america today
celebrating his massive spending
uh legislation but he has yet to face
the music
with reporters in a solo news conference
and sarah i was just mentioning and
here's the day count
55 days biden's apparent
unwillingness to take on the press comes
as some democrats are reportedly
frustrated
with his response within their own party
to the border disaster
the washington post put it this way
quote centrist democrats are nervous
about attacks casting them as soft on
border security
liberals and immigration activists are
sounding alarms about how migrants
are treated and so far no date has been
set by the white house
after the promise that we would get that
solo news conference with the president
by the end of this month
sarah look it's not surprising
president biden does not have a great
story to tell right now
his administration has allowed the
border crisis to flourish
creating a humanitarian a national
security crisis
they also have slammed this legislation
through um and they do not have a good
ability to defend what they've done
certainly i think all americans and
those republicans in congress
want to see relief provided where it is
needed
but only nine percent of that
legislation actually deals with coveted
relief the other 91
is a liberal agenda that they are
masking in coveted relief
uh and they do not have the ability to
defend that i think that's why you don't
see president biden coming out
and answering questions it's either that
he doesn't know how
or he doesn't have a good story to tell
um and i think that's why you can
continue to see him in hiding and the
media is sitting back and allowing it to
happen
they would never have allowed president
trump to go
this long without answering questions
donald trump was the most accessible
president in history
he took questions almost daily and the
pres and the press
held him accountable to that they need
to take the same standard with president
biden
and make him answer hard questions yeah
we'll see what it takes to get that
done my list grows longer every day so
we need to get started
okay sarah sanders good to see you thank
you and again
great to see you thanks for governor of
arkansas absolutely